this is sal and vai and hey this is buy
and sal
and and we said we were going to answer
questions about this joining of forces
between uh vi and the khan academy so
we're here at the google moderator site
and we're looking at the most popular
questions and we're going to try to
answer as many of these as possible
all right let's get started
so first one do you have plans to keep
your stuff separate or are you going to
intertwine stuff
um
i'm not exactly i mean
we would like to do some sort of
collaborations i think for the most part
though the answer is we're going to be
keeping our stuff separate i'm going to
be doing my thing sal is going to be
doing his sal thing
but hopefully also maybe we'll we'll
yeah the the you know this is what's fun
about it is we'll just kind of see where
what makes sense but yeah vi is going to
keep doing what what vi does and i'll
keep doing what i do uh but we will you
know there have been a couple of videos
that we did together and people like
those so we might experiment with things
like that who knows maybe i might
experiment with the vi style video maybe
viral experiment with a sal style video
but we don't know that that's not that's
not part of you know we'll just see what
happens there but uh for the most part
we'll just keep doing what we're doing
we we do we we do eventually want to
kind of integrate them in in some way
that you could experience vi's videos on
her own or or my videos on on their own
but it would be neat if you know vi does
a really cool video on fibonacci numbers
and then i come in later and i do
another video or we go deeper into the
math on it or whatever else so we do
want to have experiences on the khan
academy that incorporate both of our
videos and the exercises yeah i i'd like
to get more links between them as far as
following you following up more in depth
and more rigorously on things that i
maybe mentioned just for a second
um because the content is already there
in many cases we just don't have the
interface yeah and the other thing and
we mentioned this on the announcement is
that vi has already been kind of working
on projects and leading projects and and
i i think it'll be interesting to see
you know if
vi helps think about some of the more
exercise interactive parts of the site
too yeah and sal conveniently has
connections to all these schools that
are that have all these students who
since they learned so fast on khan
academy they have all this free time to
uh try out some projects
okay hopefully they learn fast but yeah
that's the idea
well they have they have we went to
visit a school that finished their unit
and we're like what do we do with all
this extra time and then we bring vi we
did we made stuff with balloons we we
had fun very cool very cool all right
next question
all right well if i continue to post
doodling in math class and similar
videos yes yes all right will you start
doing college level courses
i see okay do i see you have difficulty
but what about things such as
combinatorics and topology the answer is
yes
and i'm going to protest the whole
college level yes it's an arbitrary
division
um basically do we want to do fun stuff
yes we do yes it's a it's an arbitrary
division but and but we are not beyond
difficult we already do have um
uh well obviously a lot of calculus uh
linear algebra uh you know the chemistry
biology is roughly uh first year college
level we have physics we have uh
working on microeconomics right now so
yes we're going to do many things in
college level but as vi pointed out
it really should just be interesting
stuff that people want to work on and
i think core to our philosophy i think
both of our philosophy is if it's
interesting it should be interesting to
almost anyone yes cool stuff is cool
exactly
all right which books oh we can turn and
look right at the books on your
bookshelf
yes you have a large art of problem
solving
yeah which i also have uh-huh which i
also have actually most of my books are
in boxes i just had them shipped to my
yes
still moving um
my favorite go-to resource is probably
like wikipedia part of the math and
computer science sections of wikipedia
are actually very up to date by
like top people in the field who are
constantly going in there and really
making sure it's a great resource so
some of those pages are really up kept
right you know i i well kept well yeah
yeah you know i 100 agree i mean
wikipedia sometimes gets a bad name
because it's like oh anyone can edit it
what is this thing but the reality is
you know i i do looking at i do have a
lot of textbooks on my bookshelf and i
do look at them to make sure that i'm
i'm kind of covering all the topics but
um wikipedia to vice point often does
have some of the the best nuanced
information because it is being updated
by all these people who have intuitions
on things and twitch and you know just
the people who are writing papers about
it will go to wikipedia and make sure
that the information's there and random
stuff that's not in any formal curricula
which is yes so that's that's resource
number one and then the trick is then to
follow up with whatever looks
interesting so i recently got a kindle
because when i want to research
something like i want the information
now yeah so i can just download it i can
just have whatever book i want to do
research on
so i do have a large library but more
important is finding whatever is new and
that you need 100 agree 100 agree
all right the next one
where are we okay what are you
considering making more computer science
videos they were fascinating for me but
i would like to see how computers
actually work thanks for everything and
good luck with your projects uh simple
answer is yes uh john resig uh is
working on tools to make better computer
science videos so we've been holding off
for those tools where we can kind of
make interactive videos
but the simple answer is computer
science we think is very important and i
think what you're also asking is kind of
more for computer engineering how
computers actually work and they will be
on khan academy eventually so uh i it
won't be tomorrow but but they'll be
there
all right bye does this mean the end of
your signature no it doesn't
gonna keep on
doing
my signature videos which i have been
actually you've seen i've just uploaded
a video yesterday that was yes so the
secret vai has actually been here for
yeah i've been a few months so
no no a month a month yeah a month so
her last video was
while she was here and it was
just as
i think no different or maybe even
better i know it seems like i was here
forever everyone in the office like but
really you've only been here a month yes
no but
i will hopefully keep doing what she you
know what she what she's been doing
let's see
let's see do you have scrolling action
do you have any guidelines for teachers
uh i'm sorry i love your work so this is
is this specific to vi or is this for
both of us i think this is more for do
you have any guidelines for teachers to
use your videos in the school settings
they're perfect
from well we can both answer
um
i think yours are more perfect for
students who suffer from anxiety
actually maybe both of us in very
different ways in very different ways
well you get comments from a lot of
students who just i mean style has this
calming voice he goes through things and
you know you can go back you can listen
again that
like sal is not going to go off onto the
next topic if you don't want him to yeah
no exactly i think i think
where i hit the anxiety is you you know
you've got something that some other
person are saying you need to learn soon
whether it's some you know
exam or or you're in a course and you're
lost and and khan academy hopefully
helps there i think vice gives an uh
vi
more than get she she instills a wonder
which which you know every now and then
a khan academy video does but vi does it
all the time and and she does it you
know she's like you know intense wonder
in her videos and and i think it kind of
awakens you to mathematics and i think
the thing the only thing i can think of
of my videos is like not anxiety
producing is that it's okay to not
understand anything it's just like we're
just gonna
completely overload with lots of cool
stuff and you know you don't have to
understand it all you can just enjoy it
yes no completely agree completely agree
yeah so hopefully overall the net the
total anxiety in the world will be going
down which is a good thing that's a good
thing
all right so let's see do we
oh and we well on the guidelines part i
mean you know i've i've given some talks
about this and and advise run some
projects and things i think the general
idea is is uh
to to to use videos in any way possible
that can make class time as stimulating
and interactive as possible
very high levels
yeah and teachers have used both of our
videos yes tons of different ways
and we want to hear about them because
then we if we think you know there's
neat practices teachers are doing we'd
love to share them with other teachers
let's see next question do you plan on
adding a wiki like section to each video
so users can add problems and exercises
or facts and tips to
yes
it won't be exactly a wiki-like section
but we're going to have more conceptual
questions associated with videos and
you know it won't be limited to just the
traditional khan academy it could be
vise videos we're probably going to
bring in a few other people to make
videos so
um the simple answer is yes there will
be other content that is associated with
with videos uh in the not too far off
future
i'd love to see a recreational math
channel um i feel like that's kind of
what i am already yeah by that i mean
interesting weird things in math that
may not be particularly useful in
everyday life you know it's
very hard to find interesting things in
math that don't end up being useful
eventually somehow
um it's
a well-known oddity of mathematics no
matter what you do it's going to end up
being useful even if
it's yeah yes no the example i mean
prime numbers is the best one euclid was
studying it
thousands of years ago aperiodic tilings
is another good example and then we
discover quasi crystals yes yes yeah
prime numbers and cryptography and and
the way cicadas come out of the ground
and yeah so predators can't get yeah so
yes i agree
but uh but the recreational math channel
is yeah that's what vai does there's
some khan academy videos that are in
that direction and we actually are
probably going to bring in a few other
people who are
generally focused in that type of thing
so yes the simple answer is yes
all right now we can't scroll down
anymore
let me let me make my window
make my window a little bit
to my bounding boxes
i'm having issues all right
so let's
let okay so this last let's get the last
one on this page
are you producing
are you planning to produce a knowledge
map for non-mathematical subject matter
while most subjects are non-linear
there's often logical questions i think
are helpful to visualize it uh yes i
mean we're going to have we're actually
in the process of rethinking the
knowledge map altogether but the goal is
is to where it's appropriate to to have
some type of map structure so that
people can understand how how one
concept ties to another
do you want to finish this video and do
another one or you want to keep going in
this one
oh
i don't know we could keep going we can
just keep going forever yeah
we have hundreds of questions right yeah
yeah we can go all day all day okay so
let's just okay so there we go
so uh that's something no
watching this video no one's forced to
keep watching this video because this
isn't can you even leave if you want
this is a very optional video okay
i think this one's for you all right
valued an excellent video using a
foldable manipulative thank you to prove
the pythagorean theorem will there be
more yes i
i would love to get more um
origami there's so much cool mathematics
in what you can do with paper
and
also i love paper because it's there any
teacher who maybe doesn't have resources
or budget to get materials has it um
so i guess in my most recent video i
just had like a tiny paper manipulative
which was how to make a certain
angle-a-tron out of a piece of paper and
i'd like to do more puzzles like that
yes
and let's see the next one will there be
a possible possibility for adding upper
division college courses to website
thermodynamics quantum physics materials
science polymer science et cetera
um the simple answer is yes
i also think you know there's this been
this project announced by mit mitx
i think they're going to be tackling a
lot of that stuff too and i think uh a
lot of what we we might be able to do is
kind of get people ready for so maybe
we'll introduce people to a lot of these
ideas and then uh they'll be able to go
even deeper with some of the mitx stuff
which will be at you know the
undergraduate and the graduate level uh
so but the symbolizer we do want to do
these things and it's a combination of
our own bandwidth and finding people who
can kind of do them and consistent with
uh kind of how we want to relate to
students all right was there there was a
mention of activities to help boost
interest in various are these details of
how these will function yet
uh we're we're not well we're
experimenting with them and we are
running a summer camp and vi's been a
big part of that yeah and actually later
this week millie and i are gonna just do
a whole bunch of projects around the
office and start to see what we want to
maybe bring into the summer camp so
that's gonna be our testing grounds for
activities and once we do them with at
the summer camp we hope to document them
well even possibly with video and then
share them with anyone who's interested
in doing them and eventually even
associating them with specific concepts
on on khan academy that hey you know
people who are you know maybe do this
project before you learn the concept so
that you have motivation or once you've
learned the concept you do the project
or you do them simultaneously or
whatever else or this is just a random
thing that's not part of any formal
curriculum but we think it's interesting
and we'll get people excited about math
or science who knows and there's always
tons of ways to follow up from projects
and just to be able to link to content
that exists and that you know you have
there
yeah yeah absolutely
okay
the khan academy has proven it can
educate people vihart has proven she can
entertain people with math do you guys
see a concrete synergy or is this an
experiment so uh you know even the
proven we're i think we're continually
trying to prove uh you know and the word
educate this is a very open-ended thing
what does it really mean to really
educate oh no you've finished educating
yeah we're done check check let's move
to health care or something
no it's uh so i i you know i i i think
this is a flattering um i think vi heart
has proven more that she can entertain
people than then we've proven that
although you know i think the way i feel
about the proof is that yes we get many
testimonials for peop from people who
have uh used khan academy to kind of
turn their understanding around so that
that's something we've had good data
coming out of the pilots but we think
it's you know this word educate is such
a broad thing and that we we can always
push the envelope and we can always uh
ask for more so there's there's a long
journey to go but in terms of the second
part
i it's both it is a concrete synergy
like you know this isn't like hey let's
try this out and see what happens i mean
hopefully you know we're all here in 20
years and we you know a bunch of videos
later and and millions and millions of
people have experienced this stuff uh
but we will also experiment with things
yes i think
you answer that one perfectly thank you
all right now
what presentation aspects or style
elements advise video will the khan
academy look to implement in their other
videos
um as far as i know sal's gonna do what
he does i'm gonna do what i do but i you
know i i think it's it's good to
experiment i mean i i think i will you
know
maybe doodle more talk faster talk
faster maybe maybe edit a little well
we'll see we'll see i think it could be
interesting we just had a intern who
made a uh a video about his experience
here in a very vai heart style and it
was pretty it was really awesome fun and
intense
it was yeah
i mean some people complain you talk too
slow some people complain i talk too
fast yeah so i think it's good to have
yes i think it's good and youtube has
this
double speed half speed thing so
oh yeah so people should be able to get
whatever they try that that i sound it
doesn't change the page it doesn't
change the page it doesn't change the
pitch it's yeah it's amazing
so let's see
it's wonderful that you give us
intuition of many mathematical concepts
but you plan on making videos on the
rigor and formal basis of mathematics
like axiomatic set theory
the simple answer is yes
we want to go
deep in in math and science i think
yes i
i'm one of my next plans i i really want
to just get to the
i guess the formal basis of mathematics
i think a lot of people are missing that
and they in school you know they take
kind of special cases of things
and that's the real mathematics and it's
and actually i think a lot of students
would find things like topology or
axiomatic set theory on some level more
intuitive than what's what often goes on
in you know an algebra class or
pre-algebra class or what we call
algebra classes school which is really
just an algebra it's an algebra exactly
exactly and i think uh i mean i think
some of this stuff you can you can
actually teach to very young children
and they'd find very intuitive and they
would realize that math is actually
highly creative
yeah
there's
oh man all right yeah i'm excited to do
those videos all right so this
will vi hang out at the office from like
nine to five nine to five five days a
week and make videos where she just
occasionally show up i guess the
question basically is is this a
full-time job for vi
um yeah i've been
kind of doing the nine to five thing so
far i mean sometimes i show up late stay
late leave early stuff like that but
um i find it actually really helpful too
let's have a little more structure in my
life that i have like an office to show
up to that's
separate from home because working from
home has a lot of inherent problems and
just your yeah your schedule yes or when
you have crying babies at home that's
the other i don't have any no not yet
that's not too much no well here we we
try uh we try not we don't have uh time
cards or anything like that the people
should do it over here at your vacation
policy is we have a minimum vacation
policy yes not a maximum vacation policy
so yeah it's kind of crazy
but everyone here is very self-motivated
it's people who
want to be doing cool stuff and this is
a great place to do it so
yeah i like showing up nine to five yeah
so yeah so we're not forcing via show up
nine to five she has chosen to show up
for nine to five
all right
question for this for you oh for if you
could add or change anything about the
khan academy's exercise tree what would
it be
um yeah that whole thing is getting
reworked and i think that's for good
reason
uh it's
it's large and unwieldy now it's
unwieldy it's
very good like got these lines yes yes
so yeah
so i mean vi is part of a large number
of people who are uh including many
teachers and students who are uh
we're rethinking what that what that
exercise tree will look like yeah so
we're in the process of that
and if you have ideas send them our way
we have ideas too but you know it
doesn't hurt to get more that's very
true yeah
okay biochemistry or quantum mechanics
um
do you know anything about quantum
mechanics a little bit but not enough to
that one
i have to go deeper i i have to i so so
it it it it could be
so
i i personally could touch on some of
the basic ideas but i don't like to make
a video unless i can really give someone
the intuition for it uh we are talking
to some people who are you know in you
know experts in the field and uh what
we're trying to see is one if they have
the bandwidth to do it and and also if
they kind of have the you know if they
they are also they're good at giving the
intuition if they are we'd love them to
uh to make some quantum mechanics
biochemistry same thing you know we've
kind of touched on it already in the bot
you know kind of the first year bio core
stuff which you know the krebs cycle
that's biochemistry but um
it it it'll it'll it's important for us
that it not biochemistry not i talked
about chemistry in college and and i
didn't enjoy the class because it felt
like it was a lot of um
there wasn't a lot of intuition there
and i suspect that there can be
intuition in that class um so so if we
can find someone or if we can figure out
a way to teach it ourselves
with intuition and
then but the the siblings the intent is
there it might not be anytime soon yeah
it would take me a while to get up to
biochemistry
yes
all right
maybe this will be the last one 20
minutes all right what are some of the
innovations in interactive learning
tools you plan on developing together in
the future
my favorite interactive learning tool is
always something physical you do
that you make
so yeah
yeah khan academy the great thing about
that as a learning tool is that you can
when it comes to classrooms and
teaching
you've got now more time that students
can do these interactive making stuff
together
no matter where they are separately on
various videos and learning they can
yeah no that's exactly i mean you know
part of the bringing vi here was
literally you know this we we have seen
in the pilot's classes that time has
been getting freed up and that that uh
teachers and students are eager to
explore other things and vi has been
created just you know thinking of good
ideas and and i think there will be um
you know when you talk about inter
interactive learning tools i think what
you will see over time is uh we you're
going to see our the exercise modules
become more manipulative um in a virtual
sense i mean you're not going to
actually hold the thing but you're going
to be able to move things around uh that
we are what we keep telling ourselves is
we want the exercises eventually they
maybe all to do things that you could
never do
uh without a you know that you could not
have done with the traditional textbook
where you're moving things around but vi
is absolutely right we think that that's
just part of it the you know you add
that with a kind of a physical
experience and you actually are
manipulating things that's even like
paper manipulative like someone
mentioned i think that's an awesome idea
to do a lot more of those because it's
just so
uh i don't know what the word is tactile
yeah it's just easy to get the material
you can just uh exactly oh right right
accessible so accessible
right very good
all right well that those are quite
maybe we'll do this in the future yeah
we should do semi regularly we could
very good well thank you for your
questions this is exciting
yes thank you all
and happy new year oh okay